[Applaudissements]
il
j'ai quand c'est l'aviron poursuivre mon
frangin josé du tennis mais j'en avais
marre de l'ambiance est l'ambiance au
club d'avion était bien meilleur bien
plus sympa je pense que ces championnats
du monde 2015 en france avec belette ont
fait médaille de bronze devant le public
français
c'est quand même juste incroyable donc
pour tous ceux qui auront l'occasion de
faire ça en 2024 leur souhaite
c'était aussi une médaille de bronze
mais c'est pas la médaillée de bronze
olympique non c'était dans des
conditions différentes
c'était c'est autre chose pour l'année
qui vient bas c'est d'aller aux jeux de
tokyo
tout simplement si on y va on sera
performant parce que la qualification
est très compliqué donc voilà déjà y
aller et puis après ça sera bonus